EUFOR stellt seit Beginn der Mission MEDEVAC-Hubschrauber
zur Verfügung.
Der Hubschraubertyp, der derzeit eingesetzt
wird, ist die Agusta Bell 212.
Der Hubschrauber wird auf dem Flugplatz Archer
Base im Camp Butmir
in der Nähe von Sarajevo eingesetzt.
Anfangs kommt es zu einem Unfall.
Eine schwer verletzte Person benötigt sofortige
Hilfe.
Ein Notruf muss an den diensthabenden EUFOR-Offizier
im Hauptquartier abgesetzt werden.
Die Aufgabe des diensthabenden Offiziers ist
es,
so viele Informationen wie möglich zu sammeln,
um sie so schnell wie möglich an die MEDEVAC-Besatzung weiterzuleiten.
"Hallo, der Pilot spricht
können Sie das Flugzeug vorbereiten?"
"Okay, MEDEVAC..."
In der Zwischenzeit stellt der diensthabende
Offizier ein Krisenteam
im Hauptquartier zusammen.
Dieses Team besteht aus
einem Mediziner, dem Air Chief aus dem Einsatzraum
und Stabsoffizieren
die für eine Lagebeurteilung notwendig sind.
Der Air Chief im Einsatzraum ist schließlich
derjenige,
der die MEDEVAC startet.
Die MEDEVAC-Besatzung besteht aus zwei Hubschrauberpiloten, einem Techniker,
einem Fliegerarzt, einem Sanitäter
und falls erforderlich einem Windenbediener.
"Bereit zum Abflug!"
Der Hubschrauber hebt ab und fliegt zur
Unfallstelle.
Er bleibt immer in Kontakt mit der Archer
Base
und den Fluglotsen.
[Funkmeldung]
Die MEDEVAC von EUFOR ist 24 Stunden,
sieben Tage die Woche einsatzbereit.
Die Vorlaufzeit des Hubschraubers
beträgt 30 Minuten.
Wir befolgen die "Golden Hour"-Regel,
die besagt: "Eine schwer verletzte Person,
die medizinisch behandelt werden muss,
hat eine viel höhere Überlebenschance,
wenn er diese Behandlung
innerhalb einer Stunde erhält."
Die MEDEVAC steht in erster Linie für EUFOR
truppenstellende Länder und NATO-Personal
zur Verfügung.
In Ausnahmefällen hilft EUFOR auch internationalen
Organisationen
oder Zivilisten aus Bosnien und Herzegowina.
Sobald der Hubschrauber am Einsatzort
gelandet ist
beginnt das Notfallteam sofort mit den
Erste-Hilfe-Maßnahmen.
[Stimmen]
Der Notarzt oder Fliegerarzt
entscheidet,
ob die Person flugtauglich ist
oder mit einem Rettungswagen evakuiert
werden muss.
Er informiert dann den Arzt im Hauptquartier
über die Verletzungen
und der Arzt im Hauptquartier koordiniert
mit dem jeweiligen Krankenhaus,
in das der Patient
gebracht werden soll.
[Stimmen]
Wenn der Hubschrauber das Krankenhaus erreicht
hat,
ist die MEDEVAC beendet.
Wenn wir bei Verletzten sind und es uns nicht
möglich ist
den Transport selbstständig zu organisieren,
brauchen wir Unterstützung von übergeordneten
Behörden.
Wenn die uns nicht weiterhelfen können, wenden
wir uns an EUFOR.
Bis jetzt haben wir nur positive Erfahrungen
gemacht,
wenn wir EUFOR kontaktierten.
Um ein Beispiel zu nennen aus diesem Sommer:
Da mussten wir eine verletzte Wanderin
aus Spanien
und ihren Begleiter aus Deutschland bergen.
Wir erhielten eine Meldung, fuhren zum Einsatzort,
beurteilten die Situation
und stellten fest, dass es zu lange gedauert
hätte,
wenn wir
uns für den Landweg entschieden hätten.
Was eine Gefahr für
die Verletzten als auch für die Rettungskräfte
dargestellt hätte.
Von unserem ersten Anruf bei EUFOR
bis zum Eintreffen des Hubschraubers vergingen
nur 25 Minuten.
Was sehr gut ist!
Die verletzte Person war bereits nach einer
halben Stunde im Krankenhaus.
Solche Vorfälle ereignen sich normalerweise
in sehr unzugänglichem Terrain, das auch
mit einem Hubschrauber schwierig zu erreichen ist.
Es handelt sich um Gebiete mit zerklüfteter
Landschaft, in denen nicht genug Platz für
eine Hubschrauberlandung vorhanden ist.
In solchen Fällen ist ein Abseilen aus dem
Hubschrauber erforderlich,
um zu den Verletzten zu gelangen
während der Hubschrauber in der Luft ist.
Die Koordinierung zwischen dem Bodenpersonal
und dem Personal im Hubschrauber ist in
solchen Momenten entscheidend.